seeing you on the trail i was like that
was nina turner that was awesome and
it is it was fun too because like you
said when you're on the trail you kind
of run across various people
um and um like some people you like some
people you like less
that's right that's true and it's all
good but you and your team
especially were always courteous you
know that was my
experience and there are a lot of people
in bernie world or in the revolution
who absolutely admire you and and the
work that you have done and what you are
doing and i'm certainly one of those
people
oh thank you nina that means so much to
me because i was a burner in 2016.
i still get the text to prove it i was
getting texts on the regular which is
like you know i just wanted like um you
know
one of uh bernie's donors um
uh and i gotta say um when we were on
the trail
uh i didn't know if bernie liked me and
it was i was very nervous about it but
then he said to
an interviewer it's like oh i like
andrew gang and i was like really he
likes me i was like so happy
um and so hanging out with him i saw
jane on the trail too
um and i was so thrilled that it seemed
like they knew where i was coming from
and that um we were tackling some of the
same problems from slightly different
angles or perspectives but it really was
in my mind always super aligned
and when folks said to me like hey i'm
for bernie or whatever it's like yeah i
was for bernie last time too like don't
worry about it
that's right no i i've definitely heard
the senator
uh mention you in in the fondest of ways
and you know he's not a
he's not a touchy philly kind of guy so
when he says he likes somebody
you can take that to the bank believe it
when he says that so
yeah i'm glad yeah i i believed it it
really
like i felt elevated in that moment and
then when i saw him next too
like i i felt the same you're in
cleveland right now
um which is the area you grew up in you
kind of rose through the political ranks
you're a city council person you're a
state legislator
and then you hit the national stage in
uh on bernie's first run it didn't take
long for you to uh to get launched into
the national
uh spotlight uh during the 2016
bernie sanders one uh revolution part
one
uh so you end up playing a a pretty big
part in that race
uh i i would love to hear from your
perspective because at that time andrew
yang was
uh just clicking on uh the tv like
everyone else and i watch in and you
know
um but you were getting uh uh you know a
participant's
perspective on the 2016 race uh
when did you realize uh
just how well bernie was going to
perform in 2016 and that he was going to
contend
i would have to say for all of the
traveling that i did the pulse
on the ground it was palpable and i'm
sure you kind of picked that up from
watching it on tv but i mean when i tell
you
absolutely palpable that was my first
sign
that oh my god the people that were
coming across at these rallies
across the country are really feeling
something and i'm using the word
feel deliberately it wasn't in their
head it was really in their heart and
they latched on to senator
bernie sanders in the same for the same
reason why i did which is his
authenticity
his transparency uh the fact that he was
not afraid
to make the argument to make the case
that government and the leaders of this
government
particularly on the federal level have
failed the poor the working poor and the
very
middle class in this country you had
that kind of conversation
saying to the american people you
deserve better than what you are getting
and i'll tell you i do the thing that
really attracted me to the center you
talk about being a little selfish here
for me maybe it was selfish as well you
know growing up as the oldest of seven
children and having my mother die really
young my mother died when she was 42
years old
and i was in my 20s when she died and
all of my siblings so i'm in my 20s and
we're all two years apart my baby sister
was 12
and i didn't quite know i didn't know
what the hell i was going to do was not
my family's very working was working
poor
and i was at a community college the
very community college that i ended up
having a tenure track professorship at
but i was a student there
and thinking my god how am i going to go
on because my mother had no money she
had no life insurance policy
and she had absolutely nothing i did not
know how i was going to go on but i
really use that pain to catapult
me and so i graduated from that
community college i matriculated to a
four-year university i only earned two
degrees there and then i started to
dabble into a phd
before politics kind of kind of got me
but i say that to say
what what what most drew me to
the senator was his righteous
indignation and two topics really hit
home for me one was medicare for all
which i'm
sure that doesn't come as any surprise
to you and the second was
higher education to to make to make sure
that that
people that mothers and fathers and
and custodial parents you name it
college for all
because i'm a first generation college
graduate and i know how important that
was
to help me i mean it was it didn't solve
all of my problems
but it definitely helped me to be able
to lift my family out of poverty
and then when my son became a second
generation college graduate
that meant more to me than even the
degrees that i have right now andrew so
those were the
two beautiful two things that really
drew me to the senator so
in 2016 even though the media didn't
quite get it
if you were on the ground with us you
felt it i vividly remember watching a
bernie sanders speech relatively early
in that race and i agreed with every
word he said i was like this guy just
spoke
the and absolute was like
that was like like i was like we need
more of this like this is what we need
um and then you had on the other side
hillary clinton
um who i'd say i was i was
fine with but i didn't have that much
enthusiasm for
uh and so for me it was a relatively
straightforward it's like yeah i'm i'm
going to
um support bernie and then the fact of
course
you know andrean's support was you know
like not that significant a thing in 16.
um and then uh
and then his mistreatment at the hands
of the media and the dnc just like uh
like um made me even more fired up
uh where you talk about it's like while
the media didn't get it or whatnot it
seemed pretty clear to me that the media
was trying to
minimize the level of bernie sanders
support where a lot of the coverage was
like and he can't win
and like that this person you know it's
like oh this is interesting it's like oh
surprising how many people are for this
guy and i was like have you actually
heard the guy speak and it seemed
very clear um certainly after the fact
even that the dnc
kneecapped him and did him dirty uh you
know that i i think
on the merits um if bernie
had been just allowed to compete freely
against hillary clinton i think there's
a great chance he would have won
that race the media wasn't trying to put
his thumb on the scale
um against him if the dnc rules and the
super delegates weren't against him i
think there's a great chance he would
have been the nominee in 16
and i think if he'd been the nominee he
would have beaten trump well you know i
agree with that
amen is what amen to everything that you
said
and it really stoked for the berniecrats
people who believed in the
senator from the beginning resentment
with the dnc and you saw that play out
and you still see remnants of that i
think the party has a long way to go
to heal and to heal you have to admit
when you
are wrong and that still has not
happened but i totally agree with you we
will be talking to
president bernard sanders right now
instead of having to deal with uh
instead of having to deal with the
terror that we have right now
yeah and i agree with you there's never
really a reckoning in the dnc where
there's never like a maya culpa like wow
we
uh screwed that one up on an epic scale
um though there was massive turnover at
the dnc
where when people are mad at the dnc and
you probably know this you go there like
it's probably like none of the same
people
anymore but none of them were our people
either so it was just i think they just
replaced people with the same types of
people
neoliberal yeah you would know better
than i do on that side i'm a member of
the dnc too by the way
yang i am a member of the dnc from the
great state of ohio even though
some people might not necessarily know
that because i definitely
am critical of the dnc because i do
understand what many of them don't
understand is that what drew
people to senator sanders was not an
affinity for
a party it was what he was standing for
and if the democratic party wants to
have a bigger tent and have the ability
to
win offices from the local level all the
way up to the federal level
they have to recognize that that new
majority that it will take for democrats
to win
are not necessarily all die-hards they
are they believe in a value proposition
and not necessarily loyalty to a party
and especially young people yang i'm
sure you've saw that and heard that
on the trail yeah i appreciate the folks
who've been
doing the work in uh local democratic
circles and and party politics for a
long time but i also think there should
be an openness to
um where the people are heading
and so it seems like there's been a kind
of preconception in a number of cycles
it's like well of course it's going to
be
hillary of course it's going to be this
and it's like well
no one's voted yet you want to see what
the what the people think isn't that
what we're all about
and certainly that played out very very
forcefully in 2016.
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you